ja ich hole sie jetzt gleich
herrschte auch bei unserem
jahresrückblick dabei erwischte auch
dabei hier zeigt erst mal hallo [ __ ]
erste mal hallo hallo ich bin muffin und
ich bin das jahreshighlight
gewesen
ok
jahreshighlight 2021 mannschaft ja mein
letztes jahr
war letztes jahr jetzt auch kevin
schmidt so letztes jahr im
jahresrückblick haben wir nämlich gesagt
wir wollen noch ein drittes kind dann
haben wir uns doch anders überlegt und
jetzt hab ich dich mein schatz
[Musik]
hallo herzlich willkommen zu unserem
diesjährigen jahresrückblick
2021 mein gott war das sind ja ich komme
jetzt mit zu floskeln wie dieses jahr
war nicht wie jedes andere jahr und mal
schauen wie das nächste wird jedes jahr
ist anders als es immer mal ganz ehrlich
aber bei uns ganz besonders dieses jahr
war wirklich sehr ereignisreich sehr
emotional sie konnte dort zurück
gemeinschaftlich liebt das comeback du
guckst raten ob ich noch ein leckerli
hab glaub ich hab keinen schmerz aber
ich habe mir gedacht dass du
wiederkommst mein schatz
ich liebe dich
also dieses jahr war wirklich
ganz emotional ganz spektakulär und wir
haben wirklich sehr sehr viel erlebt
manchmal frage ich mich tatsächlich
selber wie wir das alles hinkriegen also
wie wir alles in dieser zeit
hinbekommen und wie ich habe keine
ahnung ich weiß wir machen auf jeden
fall das was wir machen super gerne
morath und ich und die kinder sind auch
ganz ganz happy ich habe ein richtig
tolles team muss ich sagen und es ist
einfach so dass wir uns immer projekte
vornehmen wir haben immer jedes jahr
neue ideen eigentlich mehr ideen als
zeit das ist so ein bisschen klarer
nachteil dass man einfach zu wenig zeit
hat für das was man alles verwirklichen
möchte aber ich muss sagen so die
größten projekte die wir uns vorgenommen
haben haben wir auch geschafft es gibt
natürlich auch dinge die haben wir nicht
geschafft die muss man einfach vertagen
aufs nächste jahr aber dann bleibt das
umso spannender ja in diesem rückblick
möchte ich einfach euch die jahres
highlights zeigen wir gucken natürlich
auch auf die ein oder anderen outtakes
obwohl er bei uns eigentlich immer alles
glatt läuft und nichts schief geht
schadet
es fertig wir können fotos machen
ja
[Musik]
ja und wir werden so eine kleine
vorausblick machen aufs nächste jahr ja
dieses jahr hat gestartet und ich muss
sagen ich weiß nicht wie es bei euch ist
aber bei uns ist es so wenn das jahr
beginnt dann dort sind wir erst mitte
januar februar im märz geht es dann so
richtig los und im märz gab es bei uns
ein ganz ganz großes projekt und ich
glaube ihr wisst auch welches ich meine
[Musik]
ja und seit märz gibt es jetzt praktisch
jede woche ein neues rezept auf dem
youtube-kanal von lidl und da gibt es
immer herzhafte rezepte backrezepte also
eigentlich so alles rund um und was ich
auch nicht die toll finde weil ihr euch
das auch alle gewünscht habt gibt es
auch beim lidl im standardsortiment also
wirklich ganze jahr über auch gewisse
artikel von uns wie zum beispiel vanille
extrakt und tom pappas der orangen
zitronen passte es gibt die bakterie
also die boot mischungen und das back
mail was eben zum backen geeignet ist
also da bin ich auch richtig stolz drauf
und sehr sehr dankbar und so glücklich
vor allem weil ich auch immer positives
feedback von euch bekommen dieses jahr
waren wir auch wieder in der türkei
unterwegs und ihr wisst unsere türkei
reisen sind mitunter die schönsten
reisen die ich kenne muss ich sagen soll
mir und erlag konnten dieses mal auch
dabei sein weil wir die pfingstferien
genutzt haben und zwar haben wir in
diesem jahr erst einmal bevor wir das
olivenöl gemacht haben über pfingsten
unser rosenwasser gemacht nämlich in
isparta und das war eine richtig tolle
reise
[Musik]
juni gibt es auf
youtube zu
müssen
werden
b
[Musik]
endspiel gehäuse kind
mit
hier
wo ist
[Musik]
was ich geschafft
so kam lucie
[Musik]
s
[Applaus]
[Musik]
und die reise in die türkei war nicht
nur in misrata und nicht nur in einem
beim olivenöl sondern murat ist auch
nach istanbul gereist
zum einen um katzen zu besuchen muss ich
sagen der hat da wirklich sehr viele
katzen content produziert aber zum
anderen auch um schneidebretter
herzustellen
[Musik]
juni
do
[Musik]
in istanbul haben wir übrigens auch
einen der größten glas hersteller der
welt besucht und zwar verbrachte pascha
watsche ist wirklich also ich glaube
jeder von euch hat ein paar schwarze
glas weil sich im schrank entweder von
ikea oder von coca cola hat die ganzen
mcdonald's gläser sind von dort erst mal
auf die unterseite eure gläser schauen
und wenn ihr da diese zwei tröpfchen
diese glas tropfen entdeckt dann ist es
auch ein glas von caravaggio und da
haben wir eben entdeckt und erlebt wie
glas hergestellt wird ganz normale
trinkgläser aber auch diese botschaft
leser also die auflaufformen zum
beispiel die einfach extrem temperatur
beständig sind von minus 40 bis plus ich
glaube es aber 300 grad wir haben
unseren eigenen messbecher hergestellt
aus borosilikatglas und das war auch
eine geniale reise dahin
[Musik]
kannst du mich vor waren ja und
ansonsten haben wir ganz fleißig rezept
videos gedreht bei mir hier in der küche
im studio und eigentlich kann man da gar
nicht so viel dazu erzählen weil da
immer alles glatt läuft
mit den spekulationskrisen
also die sind jetzt noch knackig aber
wenn ihr die über nacht kühl stellt dann
werden die weich je nachdem was ihr
gerne mit knackig oder 5
ich habe eigentlich auch so eine riesen
palette aber ich mag das kleine werk
soll
[Musik]
deswegen wird jetzt
meinen machen und weil die schwarze
farbe intensiver wird wenn sie warm ist
gebe ich jetzt die schwarze farbe ich
hier direkt mit rein in die saane dann
ist es schwarz einfach intensiv schwarz
verlegt die ganze zeit schon wie viel
die masse ich brauche aber ich glaube
ich mache es einfach so ich habe könnte
ich meine runde torte 18 zentimeter die
höhe der rechnung starkes volumen aus
dann lege ich später einen größeren
publikum wahrscheinlich
22 und dann rechnet darüber hinaus und
damit ziemlich den 18 192 s im volumen -
so ein bisschen die früchte und dann
habe ich die chance
mit top model j
ja
ja ja ihr schafft das was ich nicht
schaffe lebens züge kannst du das muss
man als ein problem züge in der könig
und ich bin ja auch dass man keine
logisches und keine dem zug schaffhausen
frauen liegen
was noch zwei mal vorab zucker
ist nicht gesagt dass sie es gemacht
hast du auch so umgesetzt
[Musik]
ach so
diese menschen komische man ja noch
einmal sinken dieses argument man halt
immer nicht nur gemacht
wenn man warum hast du ihn genommen
[Applaus]
gerade thoma das war thomas cook tcg
übrigens die shades of trade
wenn du nicht 18 seid schaut euch nicht
an
ja
[Musik]
sag das nicht das was es
war der wand linke im auto
die sind
rutschig
vorsichtig vorsichtig weg bringt die
rutschen vom blech
statt marmelade
mich nervt weil dass das tuch nicht
gebügelt ist
aber ich kann darüber lag schon
[Musik]
rot ist ein legales video
[Gelächter]
keine viele hier
dieses jahr muss ich auch sagen konnte
ich endlich meinen traum meine idee
verwirklichen mit pimp my kitchen das
war für mich ein sehr großes format muss
ich sagen vor allem weil ich das einfach
hier alleine gemacht habe ich habe mir
das konzept überlegt wir haben das ganz
alleine gedreht und es war muss ich
schon ein bisschen sagen also das muss
ich auch zugeben war zeitlich ein extrem
großer aufwand und ich habe mich auch
ein bisschen selbst überschätzt oder ich
habe die zeit einfach unterschätzt das
ganze so mit sich bringt und ich war
ganz froh dass die erste küche die wir
gemacht haben hier vor ort war beim
löschen der küche die zweite küche war
dann die küche von eko fresh und da war
das ganze natürlich noch mal schwieriger
praktisch von hier 300 kilometer weit
weg zu fahren den ganzen küchen klaren
zu koordinieren denn aufbaut die
lieferungen das haus der hausbau
einrichten einkaufen das war so ein
extremer zeitaufwand aber ich muss sagen
dass sie zwar ersten folgen richtig cool
geworden sind und im nächsten jahr könnt
ihr euch auf jeden fall zum einen auf
eine community küche freuen also wir
werden wirklich in der community eine
küche auch verlosen wir müssen nur noch
ein bisschen üben muss ich sagen also
wir haben jetzt noch mal eine küche die
ich machen möchte und dass ich einfach
vom ablauf her alles optimieren kann und
wird dann venstre und die community
küche geht eben alles perfekt machen
können
[Musik]
[Applaus]
das denn
[Musik]
[Applaus]
willkommen sind das ganze team
[Musik]
verpassen
was nicht dieses jahr auch extrem
beschäftigt hat war mein kochbuch kochen
für jeden anlass nachdem ich nämlich vor
zwei jahren backen fäden anders gemacht
habe das war so ein richtig großer
welser das war einfach so debug bibel
habe ich mir gedacht mach' ich kochen
für jeden anlass mit rezepten die mir
schmecken die meinen kindern um beim man
schmecken meinem team auch schmecken
rezepte für jeden anlass was einfach
etwas schneller ist was was man gut
vorbereiten kann was aufwendiges womit
man auch menschen beeindrucken kann und
dieses buch hat sich so das ganze jahr
über gezogen und ich konnte deswegen
auch so alle jahreszeiten mitnutzen hab
da ein schönes kapitel mit rein was die
zutaten beschreibt und die werkzeuge
beschreibt was die lebensmittel
beschreibt und dann eben diese schritt
für schritt anleitungen und ich glaube
dass es autos was ihr an meinen büchern
so lieb dass wir einfach immer diesen
schritt für schritt anleitung in der
küche machen was für uns natürlich ein
extremer zeitaufwand ist weil ich dann
bei jedem rezept immer die küche ganz
perfekt aufgeräumt haben möchte dann die
schritte mir überlege welche ich
fotografieren möchte wir haben da
einfach unendlich viele bilder um dann
letztendlich das schöne rezept foto zu
schießen und dieses buch ist im
september oktober erschienen was
november september oktober november und
ja das ist einfach so ein buch auf dass
ich auch sehr sehr stolz bin weil es so
ich finde man sieht einfach von jahr zu
jahr so die steigerung der bücher und es
wird einfach immer noch schöner und noch
perfekter und vom ablauf her einfach
schön und da muss ich sagen da bin ich
extrem stolz drauf und sehr glücklich
dass es dieses jahr raus gekommen ist
[Musik]
so bin ich auch weil man kann ja so
unsere tipps immer nur so hin zu tipps
lässt sich super am abend vorbereiten
und was wäre die welt ohne sallys gäste
ich muss sagen wir hatten echt extrem
viel besuch und es war ein wunder wunder
wundervolle menschen mit dabei einige
menschen habe ich sogar diese sei zum
ersten mal getroffen wie zum beispiel
meine zaubernde nicole apps die ich in
berlin kennengelernt habe und dann
sofort zu mir her ins studio eingeladen
habe und ich muss auch sagen das nicolet
ein mensch ist der mich
2021 sehr geprägt hat die mich emotional
sehr unterstützt hat durch ihre
tiefgründigen gesprächen die ich jede
woche gerne shop in dem dirty donnerstag
und ich weiß dass ein tier oder meine
community ist also eine ganz brav
community oder seid ihr immer so ein
bisschen
auch die sage ich da gespalten also
viele weg ganz ganz viele lieben nicolet
und folgen er und schauen sich auch den
dort die donnerstag an und manche die
noch nicht von ihm wussten die sie auch
nicht kannten und die dank körper passen
dirty donnerstag so was schmutzig ist
guckt die sally ich weiß dass man das
denken könnte aber man muss halt dazu
sagen dass cindy colette einfach
ratschläge gibt beziehungstipps für
jeden also nicht nur für singles
päckchen verheiratete verlobte es ist
einfach ein format was menschen stärkt
muss ich sagen vor allem auch frauen
stärkt das selbstbewusstsein stärkt und
jedem so ein bisschen zum nach- oder
jeden so ein bisschen zum nachdenken
bringt und das ist schön das finde ich
perfekt und deswegen schaue ich auch wo
ich war gerne weil es mich selbst sei
gestärkt hat meine freunde meine familie
auch gesteckt hat und ich muss auch
sagen auch der murat hört ganz gerne hin
er dachte sogar anfangs seinem podcast
weil ich immer so dass es mich so
geguckt habe und er saß auf der couch
anfangs hat er nämlich so getan als wird
einiges mitbekommen und als würde es
nicht hören aber der hat natürlich mit
gehört und selber immer dass es wirklich
ein ganz ganz tolles format ist und wenn
ihr es noch nicht kennt dann schaut
wirklich gerne rein hört man gerne rein
und falls ihr vielleicht auch fragen
habt oder beziehungsprobleme fragen zu
euch selbst einen ratschlag braucht von
einer freundin von einem freund und ihr
habt einfach niemanden in eurer umgebung
den er um rat bitten könnten dann meldet
euch doch beide collette dann schreibt
ihre frage beim dort donnerstag und
jetzt immer eine antwort darauf
bestimmt aber nicole etwa nicht nur ein
einziger gast natürlich der dauerbrenner
sturm eko fresh war bei mir zu besuch
und troschke ich muss sozusagen der
hübschen troschke er besteht immer
darauf dass ich das sage er war zu gast
aber ich würde sagen wir gucken uns
einfach das best-of kurz an ok also an
wird mir heute tatkräftig zur seite
stehen wir backen heute eine tiramisu
darf
ja
fix ist aber dass er als das 1
1 war schon also wir haben alles
besprochen über einem jahr die ist der
hammer über die schubladen aber reden
aber ich schaue ist die echt ordentlich
kann mir jemand kommt zuerst raus
ich hab dann noch den spätzle krieg mit
an ihrem laufen sie wollte gegen mich
konnten hat den spätzle teig medien
hat sie denn ich hatte nicht viele die
katze die kriegt eine antwort noch
anzeige
jetzt kommt der wolf wird hier gleich
was ist
guck mal was warum das bei ihr klappt
weil du auch nicht das ding hier nämlich
du sagst aber auch nichts was mich
erfolg war die band rennen und ich denke
warum kommt nichts auf dem löffel warum
habe ich einfach hier nicht auf der
spitze drauf mit dem zeug rein damit
hat man dort mit am besten die hütte
brennt weil ich
dann gibt es noch dazu das weiß ich mich
kenne das gut vorbereitet wissen langsam
das genau der längsten
open source denke heute noch fast feld
draufgehen okay ich bin voll bereit
das ist hat zwei und wasserstoff wasser
ja in welchem land wohnen die meisten
menschen in china auf welchem kontinent
liegt die wüste sahara afrika nicht wenn
bewegen sich schneller als schallwellen
richtig oder falsch richtig wichtigster
links die flüsse der welt der abholer
was für mich persönlich auch ein ganz
ganz großes highlight war und wirklich
eine erleichterung war der umzug ins
silicon valley rüber wir haben jetzt die
letzte zeit gebaut und haben unsere
silicon valley eröffnet also im sinne
von wir sind einfach reingezogen leider
gab es keine eröffnungsparty einfach
aufgrund der situation und mein team
fast mein komplettes team ist
rübergezogen ins büro und da können wir
uns jetzt einfach weiterhin ausleben und
austoben murat hat euch auch schon
einiges im video erzählt und dort werden
wir einfach verschiedenste projekte
durchführen und vor allem verschiedenste
projekte entwickeln wie zb auch
raspberry das ist unsere neue garten
marke die nächstes jahr auf den markt
kommt von der er auch schon einiges
gehört haben
[Musik]
das bringt
[Applaus]
[Musik]
das ist schwer
was auch im januar jetzt kommen wird das
ist unsere kinder kleidungsmarke manuka
die wollten wir eigentlich tatsächlich
noch letzten monat launischen aber haben
es doch nicht geschafft und haben es
gekommen kurz vor weihnachten drücken
wir das jetzt nicht rein wir machen das
ganz gefehlt im januar das heißt ab
januar könnt ihr euch drauf freuen da
seht ihr dann auch den daniel daniel ist
ein freund von uns den wir jetzt auch
schon seit mehreren jahren kennen mit
ihm gemeinsam haben wir die marke manuka
gegründet da gibt's dann auch im januar
ein großes video dazu aber ich würde
sagen wir gucken schon mal ein bisschen
ins video rein dann seht ihr schon mal
was
[Musik]
ja
[Applaus]
und mein absolutes highlight in diesem
jahr war unser nachwuchs machen mafffin
ist unser kleines baby und wir haben sie
jetzt schon seit juni sie ist arm hat
wir wissen nicht genau wann sie geboren
ist aber wenn man es einfach mal gesagt
sie hat am 33 21 geburtstag und mache
ist sondern richtig süße katze obwohl
ich ihn die katzen wollte ich wollte nie
ein haustier ich wollte nie abhängig
sein von dem tier und jetzt ist er
einfach da und ich liebe sie über alles
und dann kam von euch der vorschlag
holte sturm zweite kapsel weil katzen
das sind keine alleingänge und katzen
sollten nicht alleine leben und mafia
ist ja schon so eine katze die darf rein
und raus wann sie will die habt zu ihren
eigenen rhythmus manchmal kommen sie zu
uns manchmal nicht aber vor allem ist
total dankbar und ganz ganz kuschelig
und dann haben wir eine zweite katze
adoptiert nämlich von meiner freundin
und die zweite katze heißt cookie mit
künstlernamen der richtige name ist siri
auf den hört sich auf chöre leitet jetzt
sind die beiden
leider keine best friends also ist es
schon noch so dass sie wenn sie sich
sehen noch sehr
sehr streiten und sich an brauchen aber
ich bin guter dinge jetzt sind gerade
mal vier wochen dass sie da ist und ich
muss sagen sie können mittlerweile auch
in einem raum liegen ohne sich die augen
auszukratzen und ich kann sie auch beide
gleichzeitig fit haben und mal kuschelig
mit der dann kuschelig wieder mit der
und jetzt liebe ich beide katzen einfach
über alles wenn eine katzenklappe und
die sind einfach jetzt so sehr in mein
herz gewachsen das einfach unsere
familie jetzt glaube ich vollständig
komplett ist und
ich lieb den katzen content ich könnte
jeden tag areal mit denen machen
darf ich darf ich jeden tag in kappel
machen und ich habe ich gedacht dass wir
dieses jahr die zwei millionen knacken
die zwei millionen abos auf youtube wir
uns leider nicht geschafft und die
millionen auf instagram auch nicht
geschafft sagt mir was soll ich tun
ich habe jetzt schon mal geguckt die top
drei videos in diesem jahr waren
butterkeks schnitte die gestik und das
silicon valley und wenn ihr sagt sally
macht doch mal dieses oder warte mal
darf auf dem kanal ich mache das für
euch also jetzt nicht alles ich gucke
dann schon dass es anständig bleibt aber
wenn ihr sagt er möchte gerne rezepte in
diesem format sehen oder in jedem format
beschreiben wir das einfach ganz gerne
jetzt würde ich sagen habe ich glaube
ich so die highlights aus dem video aus
dem jahr 2021 gezeigt ich habe jetzt
noch auf instagram ein paar fragen
gesammelt und die würde ich jetzt gerne
beantworten
jetzt folgt die werbung und um euch
diesen werbeblock zu verkürzen um zu
versüßen starte ich jetzt ein
gewinnspiel wobei die gewinnspiele
hatten wir eigentlich echt schon
genügend im advent was könnte ich machen
ich könnte ein tag mehr mut verlosen und
gewinnspiel in ihr könnt einen tag rente
murat spielen vielleicht mit seinem
kelter paket dann sondern einfach sein
der ganze keller equipment sein ganzes
equipment mitnehmen und zu euch nach
hause kommt falls ihr den rat gewinnen
wollt dann schreibt gerne in die
kommentare
und jetzt kommt die währung
da kriegt das salz ins bett
[Musik]
ich sag einfach das gehört dazu
was auf dem herd
es gibt tage an denen man dinge tun muss
die ein mann tun muss um seine familie
und alles was er hat zu beschützen
[Musik]
was auch seine schwester auf seine mama
okay ich mache das jetzt allein okay man
muss sich fokussieren und darf sich
nicht ablenken dass alle bord
[Musik]
die kehrwoche es keine pflicht
sie ist eine beruf
[Musik]
jetzt kommen wir zum spiel wer würde er
und des fragen aus der community
gestellt an murat und mich nur leider
sagen mein mann hat mich vergessen der
kam einfach nett und ich habe mir
gedacht dann brauche ich jemand der halt
besser ist so so das mache ich jetzt wo
ich habe jetzt ein ersatz geholt und das
mache ich jetzt nimmt oma
hallo kann es für dich okay wenn man auf
einem sofa zu sein ist ja also
eigentlich ein sofa größe vorgestellt
aber
selbst damit sagen dass ich so groß bin
das passt es für lohas das passt alles
gut alles gut ich hier nicht bedrängen
er alles gut müssen nur kurz klären
beantworten wir jetzt die fragen aus der
sicht von depeche mode
das war nicht gut
[Gelächter]
das ist eine frage
wer würde er ist okay dann machen wir es
so wir machen selbst als wer stur murat
und denkt okay so denkst du wärst morath
okay meint wird umgestellt kriegt das
hin ich habe mein bestes gegeben und an
alice ziehen wird der kamera die fragen
vorher wird er und zeigt auf die ich
hatte
ihn schon
[Gelächter]
okay alles was hier passiert wird nicht
vor gericht gegen dich verwendet
wir sind jetzt nicht in einer
arbeitgeber arbeitnehmer situation
doppel
es ist gut wir sind einfach
[Gelächter]
der wdr ein jahr ohne macken rauskommen
also ja ganz ganz sicher
werde er den anderen den streich spielen
aber ich glaub ich glaube ich glaube
wirklich ich glaube ich wird oft sich
genommen ist
also ich würd
[Gelächter]
ich würde für ihn
er wird
mich auch immer also ist es nicht fünf
selbst denn murat richtig cool ich kann
er macht
ja ich musste darüber zusammen sammeln
da vergisst man die katzen dürfen die
kinder vergessen für eine schule
kindergarten beim einkaufen
[Musik]
schon ich
sag gleich dass
michael ballack
ich koche dollar hier wird schon die
hälfte wieder vergessen
schwierig ist die ich kann mir
vorstellen soll werden wenn sie wirklich
so ganz kalt ist und sodann weil es gibt
ja auch solche solche solche
ja genau genau deswegen ich glaube da so
könnte man das
machen
pikachu outfit
vielleicht diesmal auf mich stellen doch
ich würde ihn schicken ich will dich hin
stehe habe ja
[Musik]
tatsächlich ich
natürlich nett
ist wo wir es jetzt jetzt ist die frage
wenn ich auch nicht bei ihrem gipfel
ende oktober zeigen auf dem rad wirtz
weg machen ich kann es nicht weg machen
weil ich mich übergeben müsste ich finde
also solche sachen kann ich auch nicht
seht ich möchte dir 100 rieche ich hab
das schon samira wirtz weg machen die
macht das aber ich kann das noch
na gut ich kekse gebacken wurde jaja
murat schafft auch ein 40 jähriger
schaum kurs sehe diese
weise alles drin
24 zweimal das vorstelle ich glaube es
reicht für mich viele woche
werde er kuscheln
also jetzt einfach von der intuition
würde ich sagen du
eigentlich morath
immer so
kalt bei unserem ersten date hat er mich
mit inseln psycho thriller ein damit ich
angst kriegt aber nicht ich habe
angeregt er trägt damit er sich an sie
an mich ran kuscheln kann das war glaube
ich auch ich ja
richtig die taktik das schadet ich sag's
dir zwar noch ein paar ways gesammelt
und da
warte ich jetzt halt auf murat
jetzt ist er da der mann den ich
geheiratet habe und es nicht bereut habe
ja ich hab dich kurzzeitig ausgetauscht
ok ich hab's gesehen da war so ein
blauer typen er genau waren alkohol war
ja komm ja
also wir sind ja noch werden
daher hat sind aber nicht kaputt gemacht
wir sehen noch bei wer würde er okay und
wir werden jetzt gemeinsam noch ein paar
fragen durchgehend okay es geht darum
wer würde er das heißt entweder hebt die
hand oder du zeigst auf mich
und eigentlich ist gut wenn wir uns
einig sind relativ weil das bedeutet
dass wir einer meinung sind okay okay
okay klossa wer wird dr
die ganze chili es
wer würde er auswandern
wer du ich mag häuser bleiben was ist
das schönste auf der welt
ich weiß immer meine
ja ich bin natürlich niemals was eleganz
tun
[Musik]
ich mag dieses center schoss dann wenn
ich so künstlich sind brauchen wir
lassen uns dass er mich auch gerade
reingeschossen ich habe gerade ein
schuss und
[Musik]
es würde ich hier machen ich bin ja ich
bin mehr der bautyp müssen wir aktiv
aber ich würde es dort wärmer aber ein
lebensgroßes lebkuchenhaus das muss ja
machen was soll denn da hab ich keine
lust drauf das
ich habe mal 24 liegt man es innerhalb
von
sechs minuten vielleicht nicht mein
schlüssel gesucht habe aber weiß so
sauer da ist der schlüssel wieder
verlegt haben finde ich immer an
dickmanns verpackung war eine rein
geschaut
dass ich
leute grillen meine person in sachsen
lief leiter zack zack schön sauer
und haben mit sohn wir haben wir zum big
green egg ich habe ja ich den grill
anschmeißen kann man er hat immer 1000
liter grillanzünder rhein main nicht
mehr muss ich nicht machen beim blick
direkt du machst den grill auch damit
kaputt beendete mit grillanzünder
berechnet auf deine lunge ja recht auch
wenn liechtenstein reinzieht und da habe
ich noch nie gemacht ja
ja wir ganz sicher ein du musst auch
wenn mir echt die wahl hätten und uns
jemand ihn stellen wir uns sagen wird
ihr zwar nur noch einer von euch das
social media machen mensch tut es ja ich
brauche ja
definitiv sie kann auch einfach
abschalten also es scheint einfach ab
und sagt nee jetzt nicht und und bei mir
geht es um werke aus dem auge aus dem
sinn aber ich glaube das geht den
meisten davon irgendwie er mittlerweile
ja es ist immer meistens ist meistens
der mann der er aber ruhig geht mir
dabei geht es gar nicht ums zocken oder
sonst oder irgendwas zu spielen oder so
ist einfach nur ich ließ keine
nachrichten ich lese auch gerne texte
zeitschriften auf dem handy einfach mit
ich will dann lieber bücher lesen und
was in der hand ist der unterschied ob
ich ein buch lese habe ich jetzt ein
buch auf meinem auf englisch ist die
augen etwas so müde machen werden
sie definitiv definitiv ich werde 100
prozent mich am strand legen würde ich
dann der jax kies verleihen oder ich
würde ein strandhaus bauen oder oder
oder irgendwas will ich mal aber ich
kann das nicht ich kann nicht in ruhe um
wo sich jeder kann es nicht lange und
nicht ewig habe ich kann es schon sie
kann es aber ich kann sie ja ich kann ja
nur über mich nach über mein leben er
übergebe uns schön ich nicht ich mache
was und was muss ich mein wenn aufräumen
zum beispiel ich bin auch schon stand
gewesen einfach nur aufgeräumt einfach
nicht an dem strand aufgeräumt der den
ball ins wasser geschoben alles der
kirche gelassen
keiner wer macht den meister sie trage
er stellt die fragen
werden nicht geklettert das wird keiner
machen ja
ich so auch wir können uns zusammen
ja ich will das ja machen ich bin zurück
er dass der taucher anstatt schwimmer
nicht auch mehrere sinken sinken ja
[Gelächter]
ich glaube auch sie und ich würde so
gern auch einfach das mache ich bald das
mache ich ich ich gehe auf so einer
reise sowie drei tage ins kloster und
kloster machte freundlich um zu machen
dass also wir haben mehr freunde gehen
ins klo geht einfach hin und dann durch
meditieren findest du dir selber das
mache ich ja ich gehe lieber arbeiten
ich kann zur ruhe und finde mein inneres
ich
freue mich sie grad ich bin grad ich war
gerade unterwegs zwei drei tage und für
mich sie gerade und ich hatte dieses
kann auch ein kindergarten in der schule
die hole ich jetzt welcher ich muss
schon sagen so ich kann schon mal so
zwei drei tage ohne kinder ich vermisse
schneller ja aber so abends sofort schon
aber ich aber ich mache halt auch im
alltag mehr mit denen muss ich sagen und
dann ist das für mich auch jemand hätte
ich mir sind nur bei mir haben einfach
nur weil ich will mit den kuschel
ich keinen bock drauf
macht mir doch ich würde dich
vorschicken ja klar weil du eine höhere
lebensversicherung ist also durchaus
bereichern höre ich dann springt ja ein
bisschen keiner von uns war das wird
kein aber ich glaube da sind wir nicht
die typen die ich fange aber kräftigen
verstädterung und da kann ja nicht noch
von
ich hätte mir schon beim fußball die
beine gebracht
[Musik]
weil mir wenn ich kann das einfach wenn
jetzt jemand was verbreitet erzählt er
ich kenne diesen spruch ich sage jetzt
was aber sag's keinem eine das kennt
jeder da wird es immer schon weiter
gesagt es ist wahr macht mal absichtlich
damit erzählt wird echt krass
ich sag jetzt was und das können wir
sagen das ist
okay und jetzt haben noch ein paar
fragen gesammelt aus der community
fragen die wir beantworten werden warte
ich so sehr aus was ist das nervigste am
video drehen und das weiß ich jetzt
schon jetzt sagen wenn sie dreht und ich
laufe ja gott mal läuft mit 1000
studenten
irgendjemand bereit ich glaube das nervt
ich glaube ich kann es mir schwer doch
daraus halt immer wieder raus bringen
muss ich sagen als ich will beim dreh
schon also nicht dass ich meine ruhe
will das ist hier keiner mehr rein kommt
weil ich liebe es ja auch das spontane
aber wenn er halt so mit einem fußball
studenten da rein kommt dieses nichts
gegen studenten oder irgendwie
irgendwelche partner oder freunde
freunde trifft jeden die leute wissen
dass wir hier sind da kommen die leute
kommen bist einfach her und denken nicht
schon ein bisschen mut ja es nervt mich
ja nicht weil dann menschen da sind ist
nervt mich dann nur weil ich dann halt
kein feierabend irgendwann habe ich halt
und neun immer noch im studium denken
wieso eigentlich müsste ich jetzt noch
gitarre beenden aber ich behandelt weil
halt ja das ist tatsächlich ja und es
ständige putzen als wir hatten heute
über da hat mich jemand fragt wann ich
hilfe soll in der küche habt jetzt utah
zum beispiel und das muss ich sagen
schon von beginn an weiter bestrebt dass
immer die küche ordentlich ihr schon
immer sauber und immer gleich alles
wegräumen und ich bin echt froh dass ich
da jetzt aushilfe habt weil das ist
schon sehr viel als ich putz sehr viel
und ich mache sehr viel und es macht ja
auch spaß weil ich die küche hals
ausziehen aber das team ist ja alle mit
gerne von mir also da gibt es jetzt
nicht irgendwie der eine macht dass der
andere macht desto legt man die kamera
weg abgetrocknet und geholfen und dann
geht's auch also das muss ich sagen das
geht ja doch was sind deine lustigsten
erinnerungen von 2021 mit deinen kindern
bodenständig und wähler da gibt es
welche jeden monat
die sanierer hat ja weniger wurst zweig
synchronisiert dieses jahr und die el
hak papa des babys 3 das macht er nicht
er das ist cool aber er ist auch ein
bisschen die lustige wie die die admira
ist mir die ordentliche hre und die ella
ist wieder die lustige bücher
ist aufgeteilt
was habt ihr vergangenes jahr für euch
persönlich getan man sieht euch nur
arbeiten das ist alles so klasse man
muss sozusagen unser kanal als ich
betreue jetzt mein instagram kann ich
lade er hat 24 stunden jeden tag
deswegen seht ihr natürlich denkt ihr
wir arbeiten die ganze zeit natürlich
arbeiten wir sehr viel und wir machen
das auch sehr gerne aber wir haben auch
viele private momente und war jetzt zum
beispiel gerade mit seinen jungs in der
türkei eigentlich geschäftlich muss ich
sage aber es hatte schon privat auge man
sieht alles private und man sieht halt
auch immer müssten verstehen wir sind
immer die die schönen momente auf
instagram oder facebook die die die es
geht einfach nur schlecht man fühlt sich
gut es läuft etwas schief und es sieht
man halt nicht aber ich finde auch das
hat nichts damit zu tun die realität
verschweigt aber manche sagen sollen
einfach privat bleiben ja ist einfach so
dass ist es ist normal und ich finde
auch man muss auch nicht
mitleidlos so erzeugen müssen wir nicht
machen ich finde auch der kanal sollte
etwas sein womit sich erfreut wo andere
menschen anschauen und sagen hey es ist
es ist cool es ist lustig ich kann
abschalten es gibt genug schlecht im
moment im leben und wenn man auf dem
kanal geht und sie etwas tolles ist es
dann einfach ab und sagte komm ist kann
alles toll sein ja ja das stimmt ja also
wir haben auch private momente aber das
sind dann unsere private und gemeinsamen
momente private momente jeder mit seinen
freunden momente mit kindern das ist
schon werden dieses jahr leider gottes
war es einfach so war viel los nur drei
tage urlaub richtig urlaub drei tage wo
wir uns erinnern drei tage ansonsten
nicht viel gearbeitet aber wir haben
auch immer privaten moment drin weil wir
ja auch hier arbeiten oder war das
zweite mal im urlaub hier ein paar tage
mehr ich hatte ein paar freundinnen tage
ja ja und er habe wurde ich auch richtig
muss ich sagen also ich finde ich lieb
dich echt über alles in unserer familie
praktisch so kinder und alles über meine
arbeit aber muss schon sagen ich mag es
auch einfach für mich mal wie das so
einfach nur frau zu sein freundin zu
sein und dann einfach mit mädels
abzuhängen und wirksam nicht genauso wie
ich dich ernst ich finde es richtig dass
er geht und seine kumpels ausflüge macht
weil man sich da einfach auch anders
unterhält unterhalten kann doch das ist
richtig macht es das sowas ist so
wichtig in der beziehung und in der
familie dass man da auch nicht genetisch
voneinander deswegen um jedem so seine
freiheiten geben und das ist wirklich
sehr wichtig das muss man echt machen
eine frage an mich glaubst du dass du
genau so alles erreicht hättest wenn du
single wer ist also ohne moral da muss
ich echt dazu sagen dass der murat schon
der derpart war der der partner ist der
mich da seid gesteckt hat also ich
glaube nicht dass ich tennis welt
aufgebaut hätte wenn du mich nicht
bestärkt hätte anfangs war er so hoher
wie du wirst kochen und backen nur vor
der kamera da war hat er mich so ein
bisschen ausgelacht oder mich so nicht
ernst genommen aber als er dann gemerkt
hat okay die frau die lässt sich dann
nicht davon abbringen hatte habe ich
natürlich unterstützt und hat mir
hilfestellung gegeben und einfach
rückgrat und rückhalt und das ist
eigentlich bis heute und ich glaube wenn
du jetzt nicht gewesen wäre hätte ich
das nicht so aufgezogen also es war
schon unser gemeinsamer ist unser
gemeinsames ding okay die verrückteste
aktion was war deine verrückte aktion
dieses würmer richtig verrückt hier
es war das mit dem kärcher video das
wusste jeder dass war so lustig ich weiß
manche von euch wissen des um was es da
ging da habe ich einfach den max und
sogar sowie geschnappt das haben wir
gerade vorhin nämlich eingeblendet
das war das war die coolste aktion will
davon keiner gewusst hat kärcher auch
nicht und das ist so durch die decke
geht es war so lustig das war einfach
nur toll collect war echt spaß gemacht
die leute hab so gefeiert und die fans
heute immer noch wenn sie eine kirche
gerät haben haben sie den kirchen der
name murat gegeben ich spreche nur über
das jetzt im rat ein bisschen valicon
aktion war lustig
aktion ich glaube so verrückt bin ich
gar nicht was wahr beinahe verrückt
ich bin jeden tag verrückte mich aus
soll ja manchmal sich neulich gemacht
hat als wir mit den mädels essen waren
was da sind wir gerade einkaufen ins
restaurant und er hat auch das telefon
geklingelt aber empfang und dann hab ich
gesagt dass ich das einfach angehen und
dann ist da einer kaufen und ich dachte
es mal ein kunde mehr so hart und jedoch
angemeldet restaurants und so
hallo wie kann ich ihnen weiterhelfen
und dann war da so eine dicke akte tja
wir feiern heute geburtstag von meinem
freund hätten sie vielleicht noch platz
und ich war so erkannten momentan habe
ich so geguckt da war das orchester
licht wieso reingeguckt dann habe ich ja
und dann stand der mann dem ich so ein
älterer herr neben wäre dann kamst du
arbeitest du hast ja dann hab ich doch
mal einen tisch für acht und dann habe
ich das alter tisch für acht den hätte
man noch frei wann wollt ihr denn
verbergen habe mit der praktischen
später habe ich dann auf meinen tisch
gewartet hat sie in empfang genommen und
die haben echt muss ich echt zeichnet er
empfiehl gestellt und er hat sich sehr
bedankt bei mir dem gutes trinken
und die eine das war halt eigentlich
ganz witzig die eine war dann so die hat
mich so angeguckt dann hat sie gesagt
entschuldigung bist und dann wollten die
wollten mich halt frage ob ich bin
reichte war so drastisch aus wie und
dann habe ich ja ich weiß nicht ob man
auch total
ach gott
hab mich nicht auch bei songs dieser war
oder letztes weiß es nicht aber es gibt
manchmal
wo ich einfach denke dass ich lustig bin
wo ich kreativ finden da war ich im
supermarkt an der kasse und dann hat
sich so ein älterer mann einfach
vorgedrängelt es war morgens als sie
einmal vorgedrängelt und aber auch nicht
so vorgetragen gesagt hat da könnten sie
nicht mal vorbei lassen ich habe was zu
tun sondern einfach nur vorgedrängelt
oder informieren der kasse gestanden und
dann sagt der ältere mann ich denke das
waren rentner bin ich mir sicher da war
es richtig dreist und dann hat er sich
nicht mal umgedreht und sagte zu mir
tschuldigung habe ich mich vorgedrängelt
gehen sie ruhig vor sie werden und vor
mir sterben
und da hat er mich so eigentlich wirkt
oder hat dann lachen müssen lachen
müssen ich habe noch zeit sie werden von
mir sterben und dann also da so auch
lachen müssen die kasse hat sie vor
lachen nicht mehr gekriegt also es war
immerhin durch die
ist
ja das war unser jahres komplett 2021
bewegendes jahr
viele änderungen wie jedes jahr wie
jedes jahr und und man auch sehr sehr
traurig muss man sagen hier ist auch
richtig wütend ich glaube die uns jeden
auch manchmal auch sehr demoralisiert
die ganze zeit muss man auch sagen es
gab immer stress immer ärger und für uns
ist auch nicht immer einfach also für
uns ist es immer wichtig bei mir rein
laufen dass wir eine gute laune haben
das ist die habe ich auch zu
98 prozent habe ich im moment man muss
immer auch versuchen andere menschen zu
motivieren und auch lachen zu bringen
als denkmal wir uns den menschen und
morgens sagt ist es unter den leuten ins
gesicht lag desktop es wichtig städten
ja ich mach das nochmal anders ich mache
musik anmache dann morgen in marl okay
weil man sonst hin machen man sollte
nicht übertreiben weil ja ja ja ja
jedenfalls war es für uns ein richtig
schönes jahr muss ich sagen ich freue
mich aufs nächste jahr und ich bedanke
mich ganz ganz herzlich bei euch bei uns
war wunderbaren community ihr seid
einfach der hammer er unterstützt uns
jeden tag
weitere notiert er motiviert uns also
ich muss echt sagen dass stellt es zwei
museen als wird er mehr lesen und mehr
beantworten also ich aber ich lese auch
echt viele nachrichten und sitzt immer
in jeder freien minute da und schauen
was ihr so schreibt und schreibe ich
auch viel zurück und ich muss sagen das
motiviert uns auch jeden tag ich meine
wir leben unsere arbeit ich würde das
auch gerne machen wenn jetzt ich nicht
immer die nachrichten lesen würde ich
mache sinn weil ich einfach intrinsisch
motiviert bin und es gerne machen aber
wenn man dann noch positives feedback
bekommen macht man es halt umso lieber
runter im schnitt wird ein mensch
momentan 82 jahre alt in deutschland das
kommt jetzt und ich muss sagen das sind
ungefähr dass rechnet 365 tage sind es
30.000 tage die man in seinem leben hat
und da ist das bin ich es wichtig dass
wir jeden tag auch die nichts also
30.000 hört sich viel an also verbringt
diese zeit menschen die auch nicht
nerven oder oder oder euch nicht gut tun
so bringt diese zeit einen menschen euch
gut tun lasst euch nicht spalten ganz
ganz wichtig das war dieses letztes jahr
auch ein ganz ganz großes thema spaltung
in der im freien in der mine in der
familie familie
lasse sich das negativ beeinflusst
werden bleibt immer positiv geredet
das ist ganz ganz nur 30.000 tag wenn
ihr 82 werden manche werden ja nicht mal
280 mal weniger aber das heißt genießt
jeden tag ihr werdet nie so leben können
als besserer letzter tag am letzten tag
des lebens
keine ahnung würd ich mit sicherheit
nicht arbeiten das klingt es geht
natürlich auch nicht aber genießt jeden
tag ihr habt nicht viele tage erleben
und genießen menschen die euch gut dass
das wichtigste um gebt euch immer mit
menschen die euch kraft geben wo ich
kraftraum ja also vielen dank an euch
alle vielen dank an unser gesamtes team
sei es jetzt ist ihm in waghäusel in
sulz am neckar wo unser onlineshop ist
rosenheim wirklich vielen dank an jeden
einzelnen der einfach tagtäglich sein
bestes für uns gibt so ihr euch geben
wir nämlich auch unser bestes und ich
bin einfach glücklich drüber das was wir
die letzten fünf jahre machen durften
beziehungsweise zehn jahre der youtube
kanal wieder zehn jahre alt aber so seit
fünf jahren haben wir wirklich unser
team aufgebaut und es ist normal
menschen kommen menschen gehen auch und
ich bin über jeden dankbar und froh der
zu uns kommt uns weitergebracht und
zweiter preis ist das ist auch völlig
normal wir haben wir menschen weg
dienstag gesagt hast die kommen gegeben
das gefiel sich auch noch selbstständig
machen bei uns ja und es ist völlig in
ordnung der gummimischung ewig lang
nicht mehr da da wird jetzt demnächst
auch wieder kommen aber auch in unserem
podcast erzählt der und morgen ja glaub
ich online ich hoffe ich bin jetzt nicht
verwirrt und habe da freuen wir uns auch
wieder und wie gesagt es wird ein paar
neue gesichter geben wir auch
wachsen und da freuen wir uns doch
riesig drauf werden paar studenten
dieses jahr habe auf die muss ganz sagt
freund ja ich hoffe einfach dass es
dieses jahr ein bisschen
entspannt ende entspannt obwohl extrem
kreativ der und trotzdem mit vielen
kundenprojekten schon aufs nächste jahr
und wir werden auch die zwei millionen
hektar also weniger natürlich abonniert
habe das rad aber unser ziel war es
nicht klappt der abonniert den kanal und
dann hättest video er zwei millionen
zwischen ja und wie gesagt jeder zeit
wenn ihr wünsche anregungen ideen habt
schreibt der strände kommentare wir
versuchen wirklich auf jeden wunsch
einzelne macht's gut und bis zum
nächsten jahr gutes neues jahr macht
das war echt
nix wird noch bis so ja ok ja völlig und
wenn ihr denkt dass euer jahr bedrückend
war oder ihr irgendwie jetzt momentan
demoralisiert seid euch jetzt nicht so
gut geht dann geht doch mal echt zur
eure highlights des jahres durch schaut
euch an was sie alles tolles erlebt
haben und das motiviert euch dann wissen
wir ja
[Musik]
statt
von romantischen abschluss
noch mal kurz kam
im schnitt
haben wir anrufe erhalten
nicken schlafen